I said this is my favorite book but I
have not read it my height is actually
rounded to the nearest six inches I just
signed up for this to prove to my exit
I'm over in your snob I'm just an
alcoholic don't look at me look at my
car oh I'm in a relationship I'm just
here window shopping this is a picture
with my ex-girlfriend jealous I'm gonna
say I'm a nice guy because you would not
a doll get that from my actions I'm
really chill which is just a nice way of
saying I'm super lazy the first thing
people notice about me my personality
good night oh my strategy I'm gonna
message you hi several times oh where
are you down eventually I actually
couldn't think of any jokes but I want
people to think I'm funny I have
hundreds and hundreds of photos on my
phone just like this my profile has so
many typos
I bought this dog to impress ladies the
first thing people notice about me my
boobs
I'm already in a relationship I'm trying
to do this without getting this picture
is very far away so you're not sure what
I look like
I'm gonna message you five times and
each time I'm gonna get increasingly mad
that you're not responding I really I
think these friends so I'd seem taller
I literally swipe right I never do that
swipe right on every girl swipe right on
every girl I look away from the camera
to seem hard to get but I swipe right on
every girl
[Music]
take my profile pic while pooping